welcome everyone today we have a very
very special video and we're here with
Thomas brush hello hello Thomas what
have you been up to
the last two weeks well you kind of
forced me to make a game for you what
yeah so you fought yet dude you forced
me to make a game for you so I didn't
eat or sleep for 14 days you have not
left the dungeon haven't left the
dungeon
dude it's weird cuz like me and my wife
are sort of displaced we're building a
house right now so I actually work in my
parents basement oh there you go I'm
literally right now at 7:00 a.m. at
least my time in my parents basement and
this is where I've been working for 14
days because you uh you made me make a
game for you so it's all your fault okay
I feel like you're putting a little bit
too much of me there okay you so for
those who you don't know maybe you
should explain
so I dared PewDiePie to dare me to make
a game in 14 days for him and so he said
yes in the latest lie yes that's right
and then I was like oh crap I actually
have to do this so we did it I'm really
looking forward to play this big man
jump into it yeah whenever you ready a
game by Thomas that's you that's me
that's me sponsored by gamers for good
my name is Thomas brush I am the creator
of this game I actually made this game
in about place and this is working
subscribe to either one if they're
already subscribed subscribe to me we've
linked everybody I like this this is so
cool by the way thank you I mean it was
the best it was literally probably the
best idea for the game they wanted to
see you doing that the little tv mean
and alright sorry yeah let's go I'm
ready it's crazy
did this agree it's called me oh I did
voice acting that's right you did
just a man so I mean the voice I think
is 10 out of 10
oh for sure I love it at least I have my
sight and it's me in the closet that's
great oh no that's not a lot of
subscribers yeah so this is this is the
apocalypse Felix this is what the
apocalypse looks like the cutscene
artwork was done by gamers for good
that's why they're the sponsor it's
actually a former Blizzard concept
artist is running that and so he he
actually livestream the creation Oh dad
this is crazy oh look at this is just
how I started my videos dude I won that
punitive sign that's so sick yeah this
book loves you oh I love Petersons
reference I see right good catch I was
wondering if you would see that let's
say this origin set up my beautiful
origin Senate haven't touched these
things since 2009 examine the sub dad ha
ha ha
this is very accurate
exactly this is sick like this style is
so cool I appreciate you get these yeah
oh hell yeah so I think this is actually
the only thing I added which was like
you should collect yeah no I mean did
when you showed up in the chat the live
stream chat on the first day it was such
a relief and you because I didn't know
with you even cared about the project to
be like eh you just said yeah sure make
a game in like it was so cool cuz
everyone was like holy crest right here
in the chat mr. breeze is it a yeah no
I'm totally glad like I'm just happy you
did this like
spent two weeks yeah all right look I
want to play the mister be wondering
when you would shew it yeah some wait
did you get mr. B's to do the lines or
is it me no okay
oh I don't know if you know where that's
from but that's actually when he donated
200k so listen Felix the billboards in
Super Bowl ads didn't work a lot of
changed since the sub but uh pricing of
2019 we've all been demonetised
oh no and copy strike the nine year olds
have been sent to the ranch oh that
makes sense
and every meme is dead listen Felix
don't freak out I am freaking out why
wouldn't I but Marzia your friends they
were taken to the register it's for
tonight still a thing I like this
that's the worst news oh it's very much
alive I'm so sorry Felix head to the
epic shop a friend of yours has your
secret weapon it will help you on your
journey
what could my secret weapon be Thomas
you have to find out so how would you
recommend playing like with jumping on
spaces coming um what what do you mean
with punching a runner Brighton UK never
mind okay can i double jump how do I get
this tower you got it
this is why I'm really brought you also
I need help playing video you can tell
bill you just a game like a normal
person
I like the TU reference on back
yeah damn it's tight bastard [ __ ]
okay I'm going to I'm going for the the
brofist symbol it has to be mine
alright let's read this sir Stefan Carl
Steffensen all and memorial of Stefan
Carl Steffensen the true number one
deserving of the highest would be honor
oh that's nice that yeah that was that
was your audience dude they just in the
livestream they just like we're talking
about how they wanted to include
give him that Ruby of honor I know okay
so how am i doing so did your amazing
but I'm not surprised oh thank you
you're playing its kind of backseat
gaming I want you're playing as yourself
so I expect you're gonna be good okay
thank you
I've only word embarrassing if I was bad
yet are you kidding her kind of suck
this games that's so cool oh that's AI
epic I did not expect Ben Shapiro in
this game
oh hey Felix I want to buy back your
super awesome chair so why am i buying
my chair from Ben Shapiro you wouldn't
happen to have three ninety-nine month I
station coins on you oh so that's why I
collected those that's smart okay let me
go find some coins why'd you steal my
chairman Shapiro did he say this yet in
your meme review oh he did of course
yeah oh my god I'm so out of it well it
was so hard to find something that was
relevant no I was perfect but obviously
I does need some money to buy a life
insurance policy for when I plotz tombs
at the NIEM cemetery are kind of pricey
thanks Ben Shapiro give me back my chair
I want it all right what we got here
check one cabinet oh this is so fun I
appreciate it dude I love this I was
hoping you'd like it I harvest what is
this how could you oh okay that's fine I
get monetization from that yeah that's
all that matters
okay arrest the signpost read to meme
cemetery all right we know where we
going
I'm really glad I didn't cheat and like
look too much I didn't know what to get
you sitting like I did already
no of course I'm I want to save it
yeah but like I am familiar with your
work obviously and yeah I know that
quality you put into it so I expected it
to be kids but I didn't expect it to be
this College like 10 weeks well thanks
thanks
there we go here's the 3:19 chair
perform an epic 399 smash attack just
hold down while jumping and attacking
who knows might help you get you the
meme cemetery so what what side what is
a hold poke down while I go oh yeah yeah
that's awesome
we know of course of Coriana you do that
your spirits up
yeah this is our I had no idea what I
was talking this is a great voice
reverberating that's our word that I use
in my mind actually not strong
they took a step into the meme cemetery
oh god oh god Thomas no you like it dark
but this is just too much okay things
you got to start getting intense Felix
oh oh oh don't you worry about it
I figured the barrels were a good place
to be in like in the meme cemetery of
course and you got a nut goes where he
belongs
yeah so it was really tough figuring out
which needs to include in the mean
cemetery because I mean there's like
hundreds of thousands and so we sort of
everyone in that I raised yeah they want
everything we they sort of voted on them
on the subreddit now of course nice oh
it's so it's such a bizarre experience
playing a game like based on you but
it's so sure you're gonna knuckles a
tombstone
you got a knuckles for January 2018 died
July 2018 cause of death unknown
okay sure hahaha oh god they're flying
now rest in peace you've gotten enough
goals
Oh God it is getting intense you're not
joking hey is there another button to
punish instead of miles no and I've had
requests for that but I figured I think
maybe you'll get used to it
okay I feel like but okay but by the way
you see you jump in space for you some
loot yeah okay you got it you jump with
space and maybe I need to change it yeah
I'll do whatever you want me to you did
this in two weeks I think it's all right
I can't blame my bad skills on you
sleepy no let's see what he has to say a
tombstone would sleep me it's trying to
save something hey buddy I miss you so
much I doubt it I was in it was he
credible glowing alongside you in your
career though the thick and through the
significance said I was and I am there
for you dude my feels well will you find
your love and bring it to me sometimes I
wonder if you've forgotten about your
love for me never I'll never forget
about you say I like here you have it
Felix
I'll remember you saying that always now
go find your love and bring it back to
me who always my love
it's got to be monetization and not Mars
poor vessel at risk on very nice
a beloved Borba so 600 to 500 BC for
June 2018 Dino destroyed 18 cause of
death because boring
yeah again all these means were straight
up from neurotic good mean yeah oh
really yeah dude I didn't I wouldn't
know ah really lucky you're utilizing
glitch what do you mean lucky you're
cute Eliza glitches to your advantage
snow glitch well that's it's the
developer put it in there oh this is the
worst game I have ever played
come here buddy nice hell yeah
[Music]
I've got Oh God we'll get him they're
ready I think you're figuring it out oh
I love this attack it feels so good
JP oh oh this is intense Matt there is a
checkpoint and I think there's like 2g
fuels coming up so just be careful yeah
I don't wanna mess up now there's a
cheap fuel go I'm gonna deal with this
guy for you oh there's a lot of Jeep you
got one health left there you go yeah
you don't worry easy oh god I got one
health left again oh thank god okay okay
no checkpoint I like that it's a bit
challenging then how do I play with
three hands spared what the hell why did
you put it over are you not playing with
three hands I'm playing with three hands
okay where's my GP oh it's not Oh God
yeah you're screwed I like this Tom yeah
I like this that's big China baby let's
just end the stream here and just
pretend that you're you're amazing yeah
we don't need to pretend just watch this
anytime you see a missile Felix you can
do that air attack and it won't hurt you
so Oh kind of cheap
all right or I can do that you can do
that oh thank god that last one had a
peel nice that is hot
born April 20 18 October 2018 cause of
death deep fried out of existence
Thomas I just realized I haven't been
playing with wasd I've been playing with
the air oh please so that's why you suck
I was like why would you put three
having three hands to play this game
that's what I was wondering like what
three hands you have to realize hey this
is why I should stress test games
because I play like all the idiots I
don't know why I used to have maybe is
that standard oh this is so much better
well I'm actually surprised you did so
well thank you finger okay so you guys
oh I have an extra live man oh you guys
look hard you got bullied you found your
love and now that was an idea of your
just give slippy a gemstone heart and I
thought that that was the most beautiful
you did give slippy here you go slippy
may you rest in peace
Oh Felix you found your love for me
please place it in my hand so I can hold
it forever because of your love I will
always show up okay well now I know how
to actually play the games I think I'll
be all right
I'm not sure told you that I just so
this is a Donkey Kong Country reference
I mean it's really a you reference cause
you like barrel but it does kind of look
like Donkey Kong
you know like the spinning barrel so you
jump into it yeah yeah yeah but you can
actually punch it so oh I see why I was
confused about the controls because I
was clicking out of the game
I can't move I'm still saying that's why
I thought I had to you dude I'm so
surprised you got this far Oh Oh Felix I
love you so much I told you I'd show up
will you leave me bounce on my head now
to enjoy life Ursula hi thank you oh
hell yeah thanks sleepy
and by the way Felix you can't break
that that barrel of get that I want it
okay but you have to kind of get on that
roof oh hell yeah
oh all the monetization points you
deserve Felix
ah thanks man big chunga's for December
2018 died February 2019
cuz of death murdered by Karen Chagas
that's been carried guru Swain is in the
game look at that okay
a tombstone because okay why never dies
oh good you forgot your man oh that's
great that's so fun I can't believe you
made this in two weeks
well fourteen days and I cheated a
little bit I threw in a couple extra
days well regardless oh you gotta feel
well you got fairyland
wow thanks man oh that's awesome
thank you thank you dr. Bell I stole his
lines for YouTube videos
you know thanks dr. bill thank you so
much would you like to go or get the
treatment Oh to go get the treatment so
I just it's just a quick trip on this
rocket your long lent it to me
Wow Ilan thank you for such an occasion
it's reusable and runs on CBD oil Wow
we've got a brand new state-of-the-art
Rancho Mirage it'd be helpful where
youtuber suffering from PTSD after the
sub but uprising oh and it's also been
particularly helpful to their
subscribers as well ages nine and so
what do you say Felix come get treatment
at the ranch it only costs 600
monetization points now get in that
rocket at a crisis arranger oh yeah I
like how are you in the rocket is
silently already I was lonely now 300
days aboard that cold and grant rocket
felt like a lifetime supply for running
there
I was scared I was very sad I would
hungry I was even tempted to eat one of
my leg whoa I love it beware psychotics
psychotic nine-year-olds memory loyalty
to fugitive peopie has led to psychosis
and self-mutilation of the legs wait a
minute
my god the nine-year-old they don't have
legs what do you think oh my god are
those cows what is happening back there
tell us what is happening right there so
part of the reason dude why the nine
year olds don't have legs I mean
obviously it's a story telling it but
the main reason is because I was running
really low on time
hahaha and so animating legs is like one
of the hardest things to do oh really
for me at least like your character well
it took forever to animate it looks like
the running say nice but I didn't want
to have to do it for the 9 year olds
like it is it's so should I go to the
right first or should I go up here did
you talk to the rover no I'll do that
then go talk yeah go talk to the robot
can can you please get me my bleep bleep
oh battery's about this yeah what was
cool about this is I I had no idea what
I wanted to do I just knew I needed to
block the player from getting to the
right of the screen
ah so you're on your audience said hey
put the Mars rover and then right next
to it to block it put the Tesla oh oh
yeah and so it crash-landed into Mars
because it's that whatever Oh the
Roadster yeah
that's great how do I get up there so
they bake there we go
occupy Mars is that Allah Allah I Philly
have you seen this if you're looking at
me it's a TED talk
anyways would you buy my flamethrower
for just one month this Asian coin well
actually it's not really a flamethrower
if it was it would cost 1 million
monetization points so I'm giving you a
steel okay I'll take it now should have
a so why he lives there damn it well the
way the reason is dr. Phil man he just
stranded him there and stole his rocket
but you right you right click Felix
shoot the flamethrower I'll be careful
you go run out sorry this is a deer yeah
dude it's the dolphin I mean a dolphin
of course oh wait so I need the battery
I got the batteries yep
oh I see it is definitely the Tesla I
like that thank you
that feels better wait I think you put
them in wrong I could hear their this
okay good you get saved now you're doing
good yeah yeah dude I didn't expect the
reasons long should I use the
flamethrower these yeah I mean [ __ ] it's
what everyone let's just talk to Edgar
when you can all right let's talk tiger
it's okay Oh rarely tells me the sub bus
locked me in here they sent my ransom
for one thousand monetization coins
okay Edgar haha
enjoy your time in there and yeah you're
gonna stay there oh god it's the last
stand buddy
god damn you went all out of it Oh
triple kill baby nice okay I'm gonna
have five hundred wait sigh I mean a lot
more you'll find him I I added some
really big ones that you can select okay
you'll be good by nine-year-old those
nine year olds a bite you in the butt in
the back
well goddamn look at this dude seriously
before this fall I literally made a bill
that's delete like makes the boss like
half is easy oh just in case just in
case
you can't you can't beat it and we'll
play that on Tom what are you thinking
me there it is a thousand Edgar ah you
fell for it
what give me those going ever since he
got so famous you never gave me
attention so I made sure your little
friends Jack Mark and Marcia and Brad
came with me and now we're gonna make
sure everyone pays Edgar hey Alex I got
[Laughter]
no fun facts here shilling yes that's my
boy I was just about to ask that's great
Edgar okay
get down here okay all right what do i
do Thomas it beeped well you just
configure what which what do you think
Edgar would do trying people EPIRBs
somewhere oh my god stop it I got bad
dog what does he do
oh I see Oh God
[Music]
come on oh yeah I say it was that that
was Jack oh okay
sorry I Jack you're gonna have to stay
there for a while and that was my voice
as well really I'm trying to be Marcia
that was beautiful
okay so alive you're doing good
just two more I like how they're just
they're dangling showing up their legs
[Music]
I'm surprised and I think that's smart
so what about yes gone up and the cheap
deal I'll take it oh oh you can't come
up on again haha oh god I should go for
that
[Laughter]
I'm so sorry for causing an apocalypse I
was jealous and I was a bad dog
no you weren't a bad dog police will
give me which might be a terrible saying
but this nuke is about to build can you
help me get out of here
thank God that rocket had just enough
you out great I'm acting for my friends
oh it's so good
as for me I'm just glad I could see them
one last time Oh glad I could say
goodbye how was it they nine-year-olds
used to call me yeah that's right cutie
pie
my name is PewDiePie Thomas you kill
they amazing job well they have of
course by man no they made they made
this thing and they did a good job I'll
link to the game you guys can download
it check it out and support Thomas yeah
if you want to support you can leave a
tip on the HIO page it's a free game so
feel free to download it for free I'd
love you to play it and if you want to
subscribe to PewDiePie's channel please
do and if you already have subscribed to
PewDiePie subscribe to my channel I do
live streaming every day thanks guys for
watching guess that's a bye bye alright
thanks guys bye